this Monroe it's time
it's time all right Netflix dropped the
first trailer for blonde a film
chronicling The Life of Marilyn Monroe
Anna De armas plays the sultry siren the
resemblance uncanny this is incredible
only thing is it's not a biopic about
the Hollywood Starlet it's a reimagined
fictional version of her life story
based on the 2000 best-selling novel of
the same name written by Joyce Carol
Oakes how'd you get your start
maybe what start in movies
but Diamonds Are a Girl's Best Friend
I guess I was discovered the black and
white trailer which features Maryland's
classic Diamonds Are a Girl's Best
Friend centers around a conversation the
star reflecting on how she made it big I
know you're supposed to get used to it
[Music]
but I just can't and as Maryland soars
in Hollywood it's not all As It Seems
these I've played Marilyn Monroe
Maryland
[Applause]
can't face doing another scene with
Marilyn Monroe the blonde bombshell born
Norma Jean Mortensen comparing her
on-screen Persona to her real life
when I come out of my dressing room I'm
a normal G
[Music]
I'm still hurt when the camera is
rolling and here's where things start to
unravel quickly
foreign
within seconds we see Maryland's life
take an Abrupt turn from glamorous to
catastrophic Ana embodies the tragedy of
Fame and the trailer ends with a simple
yet powerful line Marilyn Monroe only
exists on the screen
the NC-17 rated film which debuts
September 28th on Netflix includes quite
a few iconic pieces of clothing like
this white dress this pink dress and
even this strapless gown and fur coat
just to name a few but just last week
Anna admitted to E.T that unlike Kim
Kardashian at the Met Gala none of
Maryland's actual wardrobe was used in
the film we did not
use anything real we got a wonderful
team of uh Tailors and seamstress and we
recreated every single piece
the same as you know the ones she wore
but yeah we did not touch
any of her real stuff Anna also told E.T
buckle your seatbelt because this movie
isn't your average take on Marilyn
Monroe the movie is not what people is
ex I don't know what people are
expecting but this is definitely going
to be something very surprising and a
more intimate uh take on her life and
her journey as a Norma Jean and then the
movie star that she became